Okay.
All right. Hello everyone. So it's May
22nd, 2026 and we are here with the
second
second session of chapter three for
fundamentals of active inference.
So we're going to be going well, first
session for my session of chapter three,
first half of chapter three, but the
second time this is being done in the
week.
So what we're going to do today, we're
going to go through
essentially
try and go through the first half of
chapter three.
So it's a little bit longer than than
chapter two. We see here, we've got, you
know, six sections. I think if we can do
like 3.1, 3.2, 3.3, we should be in
pretty good shape then for next week.
So that's kind of what we're going to be
doing. I have filled out I've begun to
fill out maybe the notes for this
session. So we've got the overall notes
on the chapter. So what's this whole
chapter about? What's the chapter in a
nutshell? All that's there.
Key shifts and so on and then the
content breakdown into core preview and
deferred.
I also have the chapter three map. At
the moment there's just section 3.1 to
3.3 there.
So that's kind of the details.
>> [clears throat]
>> Same again, but now for
each section.
All right, you got it. Now
So yeah,
the main thing about this chapter really
is
we're essentially doing chapter two
redux. We're doing chapter two again.
Except the crucial difference now is
that
it's
in chapter two all of the parameters
that we were you know, using in our
model, we were doing hidden state
inference with our with our model.
And we said, look, let's just assume
that we know the parameters of our
model. We know what the settings are
that allow us to do hidden state
inference. And then we did hidden state
inference and we we went through
examples.
But this chapter is saying, look, you
know, in the in the general case,
the setting of your parameters is an
unknown thing. You don't know what they
are. You have to first find out what
they are and then do hidden state
inference.
So, that's kind of the the secret sauce
that chapter three is about. It's like,
well, where do these setting
of parameters actually come from and how
can we find those out?
Uh and we're going to see that the
chapter starts out
by
assuming that there are two different
processes going on.
One is where, you know, we've got hidden
state inference and that's the usual
story from chapter two. So, we we use
our models to do hidden state inference
in a Bayesian fashion.
And there's a different thing we can do,
which is we can learn what those
parameters are
given hidden [clears throat] states and
observations and we can learn a mapping
between the hidden states and
observations
to update our our parameters. And
they're kind of two different things.
But, we'll see actually that the the
culmination of this entire chapter
uh
towards the end, it it culminates in an
algorithm called expectation
maximization
where those two processes are very much
kind of tied at the hip and it's kind of
unclear
uh really how separate they are in in in
in a sort of final sense. So, I just
wanted to flag that as kind of a
pedagogical thing that this chapter is
doing. It starts out by really kind of,
we're separating up these two processes
and it's going to gradually unify them
as we go forward. So,
that's that's an that's a an important
sort of preparatory remark.
So, I do I want to go through and talk
about
the chapter in general and then go
through the sections.
Before we do that, uh I wonder if anyone
has any live questions they'd like to
ask uh maybe, you know, from last
session. I know there were some people
who wanted to go through gradient
descent a little bit more
comprehensibly. We are going to do that
because gradient descent very much
appears in this chapter. It's very
important iterative solution method.
But, are there any are there any
questions any
lingering questions or anything like
that from from the previous session?
I should really get the outline up here
as well. Andrew, yes, yes, please.
Hey there. Um
yeah, just something really short and
simple and you you already pointed to
it, Frasier, but I I want to say for
everyone going forward, and this aligns
with the 2022 textbook as well.
Um so it's just really good to bear in
mind just in terms of terminology.
Um we see that the you know, the name of
this chapter relates to combining
inference and learning. And so we're
going to see frequently the the use of
the word inference and we're going to
see the use of the word learning. Um
that can create confusion for some, so I
just want to say inference is going to
be what we saw in chapter two regarding
updating our hidden states based on
observations. Learning here is referring
to parameter learning. It's going to
entail exactly what Frasier pointed to,
which is updating your parameters given
the observations you were have been
receiving and the hidden state
inferences you've been making. So
they're two separate things, but we're
ultimately in the first one we're
updating our our variational density,
our our hidden state beliefs. In the
second one we're updating the parameters
themselves and then that's what features
in the whole expectation maximization
um algorithm. And uh yeah, it's just
very essential to be able to keep those
two things um separate even though
learning is such a broad word and
inferring is a a broad verb and word and
technically in a sense in learning we're
sort of inferring the parameters in a
certain sense, right? Um but
nonetheless, just being able to keep
those separate because it'll it'll
simple simplify a lot of things going
forward and it it will just help for
like kind of a shared communication
between people by being able to keep
those those terms like clearly defined.
Yeah, the word perception is used for
for inference as well.
Yeah, and absolutely. That was I mean,
that really is from chapter one where we
the idea is that look, perception is
inference and then we
there's a story about why that's the
case and then chapter two makes that
computationally rigorous. And that's
kind of a given now going throughout the
rest of the book is we're going to
assume that this perception process is
just an inferential process, so
Absolutely.
Any other any other questions or any
lingering doubts maybe before we jump
into
chapter 3.1 section 3.1?
Uh just a quick comment about chapter 3
in general. I do not notice any use of
the asterisks symbols at all. There's no
X asterisk in chapter 3.
Which I find a bit odd.
Because sometimes the
the X's seem to refer to to the
environment rather than the agent.
Or am I
That's important then because
in my copy of the book there are very
much you know asterisks
in indicating generative processes all
over the place. So
I Is there a difference if you go to if
you go to 3.1 is have you got an
asterisk X asterisk there?
Or not?
Uh
no, table 3.1 definitely not an
asterisk. My my version of a file is
from October 31st of last year, so
that's probably
That could be that that could very well
be the issue then. In the printed book I
will say and you know this I've got
equation 3.1 up here on on just now. You
know there very much is this is the the
generative process, so we're going to
have to notate this with with asterisks
star notation.
Uh I have that in my copy. Um
Important though that you don't notice
that that's probably just a fact that it
was a cuz I have that draft as well, so
if anyone else notes that
please do uh
put that in your auto.
Yeah, I do have those stars um
like you're showing on the screen, but
for example table 3.1
um X is without a star in table 3.1.
RC, yep, there we go.
Observe Yeah, yeah. So, that's this is
one
And it seems to me that X is labeled as
observed.
It seems to me to imply that that X
pertains to the environment side rather
than the agent side.
And for that reason, it should have a
star.
Uh You are You are correct about that,
Corliss, cuz we'll see on chap- on page
53,
we cuz what what what we'll get to this
guys, don't worry, but um,
you know, first we use 50 randomly
sampled data points from the generative
process to determine the parameters
using the analytic equations shown in
3.6A and B. So, we are very much
sampling the generative process here.
We're assuming that we can have access
to the hidden state. So,
yes, I tend to agree with you that in
that table, we should have X star.
Um, and also what I have on the screen
now, this is figure 3.2. This is a
Bayesian network representing the setup
for the the problem that we're going to
be solving here, which is we're trying
to estimate parameters.
So, I do agree with that. Let's I I'll
put that in the errata.
I see we have a question as well from
Carrie. Will you clarify the use of the
word priors as well? Yes, we absolutely
will. Um,
is this term associated with the model
parameters or are policies associated
with how we respond to hidden states?
So, this is a very big part of the
chapter, this this idea of we've got now
prior beliefs on parameters. We're going
to see that in section 3.3. We currently
don't have any policies at all yet.
We're still only in the realm of
updating our beliefs based upon
observations. So, we're not acting on
the world yet. There are no policies,
okay? We'll see that coming up in
chapter six, I I believe. So,
All right, so where are we? What are we
doing? We're
I'll have to note that for later,
Corliss.
I'll put that in the errata, though.
I want to go back to the equations here.
3.1.
So, we're starting out from
This is our generative model. We've
we've done this many times before. And
we're now trying to estimate what the
parameters are. So, what these beta zero
and beta one things are.
Under a very interesting assumption. And
the assumption is that we're going to be
able to observe the hidden states X star
and the observations Y. Okay? That's
kind of weird. That sort of flies in the
face of what we've been saying the
epistemic limitations are so far. You
know, we only observe things
Y, light intensities, and the true fruit
sizes are unknown.
It it's helpful to assume that
in the in the case where we want to
learn model parameters that we can
actually observe hidden states and light
intensities. And what we're going to do
is we're going to learn a mapping
between them.
So, instead of being given
instead of being given this
just, you know, from upon Y
we're going to we're
rather this is the the the environment
the actual model that corresponds to
that is 3.2.
Uh 3.1, 3.11, 3.2 is what I want. I see
how that's going to order things. That's
very interesting. So, this is our model
that we're going to assume. Um
And the idea is, okay, yes, the the
generating process by which observations
come in it's linear again, but we don't
know what beta zero are and we don't
know what beta one are. Yes, that should
be beta one not beta A.
But and I this figure 3.2 makes this
very clear.
Uh chapter three, chapter three.
Come on. Come on.
So, what we're going to do is we're
going to assume that we can observe
hidden states. So, this is one hidden
state, two hidden state, three hidden
states. You know, they're indexed by I
in this plate notation.
Uh and we want to infer
or rather it's a Bayesian network for
linear regression with known or observed
X and Y
and phi uh the the phi
is just our grouping for our parameters.
So, this thing over here, theta and
sigma y, that's just phi. Those are our
parameters.
Uh they're used to observe well, to to
estimate the unknown parameters for
multiple samples.
So, it's a bit of a weird setup.
It can be a bit kind of strange to get
get used to.
So, what does that actually mean? If I
want if So, figure 3.3, this is yet
another visual representation of what's
going on.
So, we have we're going to assume
and again,
this this comes with the
the text. So, on page 53,
well, page 52, the generative model will
use the same generating function. So,
we're using exactly the same linear
function.
Except the model the parameters beta
zero and beta one are unknown and they
must be estimated. So, we don't know
them.
Uh the generating function and samples
are shown in figure 3.3. So, this is
3.3 here.
Uh first, we use 50 randomly sampled
data points from the generative process.
Okay, so that's what Kerberos was saying
earlier. These samples here are actually
coming from the process. So, this food
size is the real food size and it maps
to a real light intensity. So, you know,
maybe this is one that's around two and
that's going to map to about eight also.
Uh and we're going to take 50 such
samples. Don't worry. Don't spend too
much time worrying about where that
comes from right now. It'd be very
helpful if you just assume that this is
possible, that we can sample these
things from the real uh the real
process.
Uh and then what we're going to do is
we're going to update our beliefs or
well, determine what the parameters
should be if we can do the sampling
process. I see there was a question in
the chat
as well.
Oh, yes. Uh so, that a common name for
the parameters at issue is using we use
the Greek letter theta,
which is kind of the circle with a line
through it. That's just a Greek letter
and that's what we use typically to
denote parameters. Greek letters are
used all over the place for that sort of
thing.
So the the idea here is, look, we're
starting out from data
that is to say labeled data. So I have a
food size two, that's labeled with an
observation that's about eight.
And so on and so on. So we have these
you might imagine a big kind of table of
of numbers that are sort of two points.
And what we want to do is we want to
from the shape of this data
determine what we think the parameters
beta zero and beta one should be that
would generate the observations that we
saw.
And there's all kinds of methods for
doing this.
But the the the first way that we start
out with
you know
uh this this section is called
estimating deterministic model
parameters.
This
this initial way of of doing parameter
estimation, we're going to assume that
the model the the parameters are just a
number and we just need to predict that
number. Okay, it's a fixed number. We
just don't know and we're going to try
and predict it. In section 3.2, we're
going to relax that assumption and
assume that the parameters are
themselves probabilistic. They're not
just kind of a fixed thing.
Righty-oh. So
there's a couple of equations then about
this. [clears throat]
Maybe just real quick, this is helpful
background. If I go down to here.
Equation 3.3 on 51, 3.2 27 3.3.
What is this? This is our our likelihood
uh once again.
So this is the central thing that we saw
in in chapter two. Uh this is telling us
how likely a given observation is
um
under our under our modeling
assumptions. We're typically going to
take the log of this and then the
negative of the log of this and then
we're going to do some sort of
optimization procedure.
Uh is what's going to happen, so.
That's very much the the central
equation
for most of the optimization we're going
to do.
Yes, so
you know, as I explained previously, the
goal and and the idea with maximum
likelihood estimation, this is what we
saw in chapter two towards the end, is
we want to find the maximum of the log
of this thing. Okay? That's going to
tell us what we think the
best value of the hidden state is given
the observation, but we can do the same
process
to find the best value of the parameters
that's
that gives us the mapping that we we
have between food size and light
intensity.
Uh, yes, so in this case we're
interested in estimating theta, which is
composed of two parameters, beta zero
and beta one. There's any number of
parameters we could we could
have.
So, equation 3.4, that's just the log of
this thing once again, so that turns it
into the log the sum of the logs.
And 3.5,
this is really just a recapitulation
of what I said, so where am I?
3.5. So, mathematically, what I just
said is expressed by this here.
The value for the parameters, the
maximum likelihood estimate for the
parameters, not for the hidden states,
for the parameters,
is given by the value of theta
that, when plugged into the log
likelihood likelihood function,
gives you the maximum log likelihood. In
this case, this is actually the negative
log likelihood.
I can't remember how he defines it if he
defines it as negative or not. I don't
think he does.
But I think
the little L function should have as its
argument theta as well.
Yeah, that's correct. This is a This is
a typo here. It should be theta.
The The LaTeX rendering does this
automatically, so
this should not be X, this should be
theta, this should be a parameter. So,
yet another errata.
Uh, I change to theta R.
I'll go back and do that later. Thanks
for that. Now,
if we assume that the form of the models
is everything that we've seen so far, so
rather
3.1, 3.2, and 3.3,
then
as he says, with some calculus and
algebra, we can determine
the equation for each parameter that
tells us what the parameter would have
to be.
So, this is 3.6A
and B.
Where are they? They are here.
Oh, was that Was there a question, Jim
Boma? No, no, no, no. Sorry.
So, fine. I I think you're I think
you're not muted. If you could just mute
Unless you have a question, do do you
mind? Yeah. No, no, no.
So, I don't want to get I don't want to
get bogged down on this too much, but
that what what is what this is to say is
that
if we make those assumptions about the
model,
then the value of the parameter So, we
have a linear model. The value of theta
for the parameter that's is beta zero is
given by this equation here. So, the
mean observation minus beta one times
the mean state.
Uh
and then the same again for beta one.
That's given by this horrible
scary-looking thing here.
I don't want to dwell too much on the
the analytical details. We can we can do
that later.
But,
this this is like a an exact solution to
what the parameters are in the case that
they are we assume they're
deterministic. Okay, so they're not
probabilistic at all.
Very nice. Now,
Sorry, that
that variance seems to be indicated by
different form of S. So, why is that
different from the normal S used for
priors?
Yeah, this this is Oh, well, first of
all, this is yet again
the LaTeX is not quite rendering this
correctly.
It's not a problem in terms of the the
meaning, the semantics. What what what
you're getting at is, you know, well,
why why this particular S?
Um I think this is just a choice of
notation, to be honest.
Um
you know, so between X, Y, and this S
thing is the sample variance. So,
it's just how he's chosen to denote
variance. A bit bit of a strange choice,
I must say.
Yeah, there's an inconsistency in my
copy of the book as well. At at this
point, it uses that fracture
uh form of S, but in equation 3.79
later in that chapter,
uh you know, the addition to the
chapter,
it's it it uses a standard S. So, even
in the the copy of the book, uh there's
inconsistency.
Uh okay. Yeah, that's a bit of a shame.
Um
I think we'll we'll we'll have to note
that as yet another errata, potentially.
Uh the thing though about this section,
this is a 3.4 really captures the ideas.
So, now now we're now going to move from
what we did in terms of looking at the
exact solution to deterministic
parameters, and we're going to now start
learning model parameters with maximum
likelihood estimation.
Uh
or rather, this is a visualization of of
what we did before. So, on the left, we
have
uh we've taken eight samples from the
hidden state, and we've done this I
think 100 times. Is that correct?
Uh hidden state estimation, yeah. So,
okay. General process sampled 100 times,
eight with eight points each, to produce
different estimates for beta zero and
beta one.
So, in this case, we've got three, four,
five, six, seven, eight. That's
those points there,
we can fit a line to, that is our
estimate as to what the real parameters
should be in terms of how they define a
line, okay? The red line is the real
setting for the generative process.
But you might imagine we've got 100
different lines that fit
eight different data points, and they're
going to give roughly the same line, but
there's a bit of variation around that
because we're sampling from the
generative process.
So, all of these lines, every single one
of them, is a plausible
uh setting of the parameters that would
give us the results that we observe,
okay? But of course, they're all
different from the real generative
process, or the real line that is
defined by the parameters in the
generative process. So, the the
point of this example is to say, look,
you're you're you're typically going to
It's typically going to be the case that
the setting of the parameters You can
have many different settings, or
slightly different settings of the
parameters that would give you the same
observations, or very, very, very
similar observations. So, you're never
quite going to get
um exactly the you know, the the
parameters from the generative model.
And you know, he says that, okay, so we
can use 3.6a and b to obtain the
following rounded results. Beta zero is
about 3.062, and beta one is about 1.
19.
Uh 1.9 rather, and that's very, very,
very close to what the real generative
process parameters are,
uh which is nice.
Right, yeah. Now, much more exciting
is exactly the same setting again,
where
we're doing precisely the same thing.
We're doing maximum likelihood
estimation,
but we're doing this with gradient
descent now, okay? So, instead of having
the analytic 3.6a and 3.6b equations
that we're plugging in to to find our
parameters, we're now going to say,
let's start out with the the negative
log likelihood,
and let's kind of crawl along it in a
way that that gets us to the minimum
negative log likelihood,
which will be the maximum log
likelihood, okay? The maximum likelihood
estimate for what the parameters are
that give us the data.
So, this is figure 3.5. This is a visual
representation. What this shaped thing
is, what this surface is, is the
negative log likelihood, and that is
given in
equation 3.7. Just want to quickly show
it.
Uh we've seen it before though, so it's
not too crazy. 3.7's here.
Okay, so we're just taking the negative
of the log of the likelihood. Okay, and
the likelihood is given by a linear
generating function in this case.
So that is literally what you're seeing
here. Chapter three.
And what we're going to do is we're
going to start out on the surface
somewhere, okay? And that's going to
correspond to a setting of the
parameters, which is typically going to
be very, very bad.
But what we're going to do is we're
going to walk down the gradient, the
slope of the negative log likelihood,
and that's going to end up be like we'll
end up sort of getting to a minimum
somewhere.
And the value of the parameters at that
minimum is going to be the maximum
likelihood estimate for the parameters.
Uh and the cru- the crucial thing to
show here
uh
I'm going to go back to here, equation
3.8.
That defines mathematically what's going
on.
So here, remember, this is there's a
little bit of bookkeeping here.
Theta is the value of our parameters.
What are our parameters? Well, they're
beta one and beta zero. We've only got
two parameters, okay?
What this is saying is that the value
for our parameters after having done one
step
of gradient descent
is going to be the value of our
parameters now
minus some small number times the
gradient of the negative log likelihood.
Uh there's actually a bit of
difference here in terms of how things
are expressed in the book. He's got
negative kappa times negative
gradient of the the log likelihood
because he defines the negative log
likelihood with this this minus sign. So
that's a bit of a
uh an unfortunate divergence. Not
important for physical intuition though.
So all that is to say is that this is
just a mathematical representation of
what I was showing before, and hopefully
I can zoom in close enough.
So we look on on on the left here, we're
looking straight down
on on the ball, right? On the negative
log likelihood. And we're starting out
here. I don't know if I can zoom very
well.
Okay, we're starting out maybe at this
little red triangle, and we make one
step, okay? And then we end up there.
They're they're very very close to
steps. So, usually the steps are very
small in size. And we're going to do
this, I think uh 500 times.
Something like that. Yeah. No, 700
iterations. So, there are 700 little red
triangles here that correspond to 700
steps.
Uh so, you typically have to do this
process iteratively. You know, you take
a step, you go down the negative log
likelihood, very nice. You take another
step, you go down the negative log
likelihood. At some point, you stop
changing
very rapidly. And after some after some
amount of not changing very much, you
say, "All right, look, we've reached a a
minimum. We're going to take the value
of the parameters at that minimum. And
that's going to be our maximum
likelihood estimate for the parameters.
That is a massive whirlwind tour of an
entire topic in probabilistic machine
machine learning more generally that
takes a long time to to get through and
get intuition of, but that is at least
the core idea uh
about how how we do MLE with gradient
descent.
That brings us to the next section,
where we now generalize this to the case
of multiple parameters. So, we're going
to do exactly the same thing again.
We're just going to have more parameters
in our model.
I'll just stop here real quick. Are
there any Are there any questions about
what we've looked at so far? That is a
bit of material.
Indeed.
Let me check the chat. I see there's
some activity there.
Do do do. Andrew's been nice and active.
There we go, very nice. Andrew, yes.
Yeah. Uh
thanks. Yeah, I was just addressing more
on the what are the priors uh question
in the chat, if that's useful to anyone.
Um
yeah, and I I think you're you're doing
well on on covering these things, and I
guess just to add my two cents is that
we see a lot of similarity between
chapter two and chapter three as far as
we're going back and looking at things
like gradient descent again. It does
start to look like, "Oh, we're just sort
of flipping the situation around where
Whereas in chapter two, we were taking
our parameters as given, and then we
take a sample, a new observation is
given, we update our X or beliefs.
Now, we're taking the beliefs as given
during this this M step in the learning
of the parameters, right? So, I just I
think it's as far as digesting all this
material at once, it is useful to see
the overlap between the two chapters.
In that way, it kind of constrains how
much you might actually need to know
about how these things work. That said,
they're still distinct, and we recognize
that they're two separate things that
get linked together in this EM sort of
loop. Um Yeah.
Nonetheless, we see like with the figure
you were just showing, like we're still
effectively kind of traversing these
contours in what is now a parameter sort
of space.
Um and so, that's a way of sort of
visualizing these things.
No, absolutely. That That is We're not
going to get to expect expectation
maximization today, but that very much
is the centerpiece of this chapter, and
it will tie together the loose and
disparate threads that might seem loose
and disparate now,
for sure. So, that is that is an
important thing to try and keep our our
mind on. Things things will hopefully
get more intelligible as we as we close
in on that.
I don't want to spend too much time on
generalizing. So, today we're okay with
3.2 section 3.2. We can generalize this
story to
a case where we have multiple
parameters. And in order to do that, we
have to use some machinery from an area
of maths called linear algebra.
Uh
wherein we have this idea of matrices
and and vectors and and linear
transformations and that kind of thing.
So, the the language of this section is
expressed in terms of linear algebra.
Uh
which is an extremely important thing to
uh to really kind of
uh appreciate. So, if I go into chapter
three here,
I go into my notes,
section 3.2.
Scroll down. There is, of course, an
entire um
you know, appendix in the mathematical
appendix C on on on mathematical
background. I would strongly recommend
that you read the section on linear
algebra. Linear algebra is foundational
to basically everything. So,
but in this in this uh area I put some
additional resources. I've linked
3Blue1Brown's ex-
once YouTube series, The Essence of
Linear Algebra, where he goes through in
a very conversational manner and
visually explains a lot of this
material. That would be an excellent
thing to consult if you haven't already.
And there is also an open-source
textbook, another textbook on on linear
algebra, which I put there, Linear
Algebra Done Right by Sheldon Axler.
Great book. Let's not going to focus.
Anyway, so it's there in the notes, but
it for those who are interested uh in
going further, they those would be
excellent resources to to consult.
So,
yes, really, I don't unless people
really want to see it, I don't want to
show too much of that here other than
>> [clears throat]
>> to say, if we go to 3.12,
3.12,
Koda kind of does an interesting thing
with uh
how it how it uh or- orders things here.
1 2 1 2 1 2. There we go.
The idea is, instead of having uh
just
two parameters,
actually, maybe it would be better to
show that. 3.10.
So, instead of having just two
parameters here,
and by the way, what I'm showing now is
linear algebraic notation for matrices
multiplying vectors. I can't explain
that
uh
in a way that's
going to leave enough economy to explain
the rest of the things I need to
explain.
But um do consult these other resources
if you're unfamiliar with this kind of
notation.
So, you know, 3.10, all this is showing
is that, look, we only have two
parameters, very nice, but we can
generalize this to having as many
parameters as we would like in in some
sense with 3.11.
So, now instead of two, we have C
parameters, okay?
But, we can express the same exactly the
same idea with this linear algebraic
notation, which is very nice. And we can
very succinctly represent this whole
thing. So, we have our big old table of
hidden states, a vector of parameters,
and then another vector of noises.
This can be extremely succinctly
represented
by this notation here.
This is exactly the same thing that we
saw when in chapter 1 and 2, except now
we have this kind of bold notation. What
that's saying is that the things in bold
are either vectors or matrices. They're
lists or tables of numbers.
So, that's a very important that's a
that's a convention that will be used
throughout the rest of the book, and
indeed for most of the things that we
will see.
Um
So, it's important to to see that. And
obviously in three in figure 3.6,
it captures this out in a little bit
more detail. I'll just briefly show that
figure.
3.6, this one here.
So, if we kind of zoom in and look at
what that X matrix is,
this is the list of data points that we
have that are
data points from the generative process.
So, they're food sizes, they're hidden
states.
And the idea is we have each row is
going to correspond to Here's one hidden
state, here's another hidden state,
here's another hidden state.
And they're all of size or all of length
C, okay? That's the idea.
So, this is this is kind of a pic a
pictorial representation or diagram as
to what
what that table of numbers, what that
matrix really is, okay?
Okay dokey. Now, there's some
there is some talk then about the actual
operations that we need to do in 3.14.
Uh
Yes, okay.
Yeah, so this this culminates then in uh
wait, Peter, I see we have a question.
Fire away. Yes.
Hi. No, it's not a question, just a
remark that I think in the caption of
figure 3.6 there is a typo.
Uh
typo and error. So, he's mixing N and N
is sometimes six and N is sometimes
seven.
So, here I think I starts from zero and
goes to six, so you have seven samples.
Uh but that means the dimension of the
matrix should also be our N plus one.
Uh very very perceptive. Yeah,
well, six versus seven. I don't have a I
don't have a value for N being
six in my copy.
Okay. Well, I see the caption.
Um
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, well, I mean, this
is the caption here as well.
Yeah. So, yeah, we should have seven
samples. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7.
Very much. So, you're saying you've got
actually six
um
N N equals six samples. Yeah, sometimes
he uses N for the number of samples.
But here, if you look at the
subscripting,
uh so below the state things, yeah.
Yeah. Just Yeah, I was confused at some
point. And and if I may, I have another
question. That's Yeah, that's what
you're referring to?
Yeah.
In the introduction of the section, he's
saying we're going to work with
non-linear generating functions.
But it turns out that the generating
function is is is just you have multiple
state variables, and it's still a linear
combination of those. I was confused why
he he's stating it like that in in
3.2.
Uh
3.2, yeah, I see. Yeah, I mean, we
absolutely do have just linear
generating functions here so far.
>> Yeah.
Uh
not non-linear.
I could see uh
you're you're absolutely correct on that
point.
That said, I do think that
potentially the wording I I think that
wording is misleading for sure. I don't
know if it should be considered to be a
rather or not.
But whenever we start getting into
linear Gaussian systems in 3.4,
it might be that Sanjeev had a
particular like
preference for how he wants to present
that and the the LGS linear Gaussian
systems are frequently used in
non-linear
circumstances and are very amenable to
that.
And so I think it's it's my
interpretation is Sanjeev was probably
going to go into like oh, eventually
we'll be
you know, applying the LGS or
multivariate LGS systems uh
to to kind of non-linear problems or
non-linear functions, but still for the
time being here in chapter three, we'll
still keep our parameters around a
linear function for the sake of
simplicity to to sort of like
demonstrate the use of these
if that makes sense.
Yeah, that is confusing though.
Yeah, okay. I can't find that just now,
but I'm sure it's there. So I've
>> [clears throat]
>> left a note to myself to go and find it.
Yeah, yeah, let me let me rephrase cuz I
think I don't want to add my own
like I don't want to confuse with my own
words here, too. Um it's that you can
you can
it's here on
um
page 65, I think, 3.4.
To start, we'll introduce linear
Gaussian system, which is the extension
and generalization of the hidden state
inference model explored in chapter two.
Um it relates it to Kalman filters,
which is a similar question we saw I
think the other day where someone asked
what's the relationship between this and
Kalman filters for those who are
familiar with those. And finally,
indeed, as we will see in part two, the
algorithms for active inference in
continuous state spaces can be viewed as
an all-encompassing nonlinear Gaussian
system of further generalization of the
LGS. So, yeah, let me rephrase that and
say that it's the it's that the LGS has
been expanded.
Um
I I think it comes back to the the same
reasonable complaint or or criticism
though. Um you know, it should probably
say linear not nonlinear there in this
chapter. Yeah.
Yeah.
All right. Well, we'll see more of that
when we get to 3.4. But, um just running
out through uh 3.2 here, the the
culmination of this
um
this section where we have
Let me sure I get the section name
right.
Maximum likelihood estimate for multiple
parameters. The The culmination of this
is something called the normal equation,
which is an exact analytic solution for
what the parameters are given the data
matrix and uh observations that we've
made.
So, you know, the way that we sort of
get there is we say, "Look,
what what we we want is we want a
maximum likelihood estimate of the
parameters. In this case, we have uh
correctly identified the the argument of
the negative log likelihood to be the
parameters themselves.
Uh
what ends up happening in this some
linear algebra that that happens in
order to be able to show this. I'm not
going to show it, but uh 3.19
this relationship here between the data
matrix and the
uh the observations will actually give
you exactly what the parameter should
be. Uh which is very, very nice. So,
however, in in the general case, so this
this is called the normal equation. In
the general case, uh it's a very, very
difficult to evaluate what this should
be. And so, most of the time for a lot
of interesting problems, we don't use
the normal equation cuz it's kind of
hard to to evaluate. So,
yes.
Now, 3.3
we then we then effectively do this. We
we do an example of multiple linear
regression.
Um it's really the same thing as the
previous example where we did it
univariately.
Uh so I don't think there's a lot to
really kind of show there. But the So
that that kind of takes us to section
3.3, Bayesian linear regression. And
this is where This is where the chapter
really sort of begins to come into its
own
uh as opposed to an extension of just
chapter two.
So
I want to go back to here.
So the idea with Bayesian linear
regression is
we could
assume that our parameters are, you
know, they're point estimates, they're
deterministic.
Or we could assume that they are like
hidden states in some sense. And in what
sense? In the sense that they have an
uncertainty associated with them. And
they're things that we can infer.
So this is This is a very powerful idea
that, you know, we're we're starting to
gesture towards the idea that our
parameters are themselves uncertain. And
they have probability distributions
associated with them that we can do
inference with respect to, Bayesian or
otherwise. So
the chapter It starts out by introducing
something important called the
multivariate normal distribution. Okay,
so the normal
distribution is a bell curve or Gaussian
distribution.
The multivariate distribution is just an
extension where we have
the same thing over multiple values. So,
you know, we have a two-dimensional one
in this case. We saw this again
in previous chapters.
There's an analytic version, so you
know, equation 3.23 that gives you the
the analytic expression for the
multivariate normal.
But our our values are are typically
going to be encoded as vectors. They're
going to be multivariate, so it's
important to get used to the idea of
working with with these kinds of
distributions.
Uh so
the only thing that is really, I think,
important with respect to the
mathematics to note,
if I go to figure 3.9,
>> [clears throat]
>> so we're now looking sort of down upon
the the hill of the multivariate normal,
a two-dimensional multivariate
distribution.
The idea is that instead of being
uh characterized in terms of a mean and
a variance, a mean and how far things
are spread out, we now have a mean and a
covariance matrix,
okay? I'm not going to be able to
explain what the covariance matrix is in
enough time, but it is uh I just a a
matrix, a list of numbers, that
describes how kind of shaped the
distribution is, okay? So, we have this
idea of covariance matrix with just
diagonal entries, and they're all the
same, that gives us kind of
spherical-looking one.
If the diagonal entries are different,
we have a kind of squished distribution
in the direction of uh the smallest
parameter, and we can imagine
combinations thereof as well. So,
they're not always going to be nice
spherical uh things, they they're going
to be, you know, potentially squished in
one direction or or another.
Andrew, yeah.
Yes, so if we go and this is yet again
So, example 3.5, this is the central
example of of the whole chapter.
Uh
in in sort of table 3.2, I don't know if
we have the tables visualized yet, I
don't think we do, do we, Andrew?
No, we don't have the tables yet,
unfortunately.
>> enough. Yeah. We have about 80% of the
equations thus far, the figures.
>> So, that is that is yet again we have
a recapitulation of the the table from
the beginning of the chapter,
but if I go to
this equation,
3.27,
27, here we go.
So, what this is really just an
expression of the kind of model that
we're dealing with now, and what's is
probabilistic and what is not
probabilistic, okay?
So,
I'm not sure if we should dwell on this
too much, but the idea is that our
likelihood now is multivariate. It has
multiple
different parameters and and and hidden
states. That's expressed in this linear
algebraic notation.
Uh we assume that our covariance is
just kind of ones on the diagonal that
are scaled by some number. So, we're
going to have a nice spherical-looking
thing.
Uh and we're now trying to infer the
parameters, the linear parameters here
in theta.
That's That's the setup. Now, we can do
this specifically
if we come here. Now, this gets to
Carrie's question from earlier.
3.28
We can do this now in a way that we have
prior beliefs about what the parameters
are.
So, you know, we we have a a likelihood
distribution that we saw that tells us
how likely observations are given our
parameters, but we're also uncertain
about our parameters. So, we have a
prior belief about what they are with
their
uh you know, values and so on.
And we can now do Bayesian inference on
our parameters. That's That's
the crucial the crucial observation
here.
So, and this is actually shown quite
nicely
in figure 3.10.
Do do do.
>> [clears throat]
>> So, we have the you know, the factor
well, the the Bayesian network that
expresses this idea now.
So,
our parameters
are themselves random variables
that are
given by a certain relationship of of
other parameters. I mean, in this case,
a mean of a multi- well, of a of a of a
Gaussian distribution and
and and and and a variance.
And we can do good old-fashioned
Bayesian updating now in much the same
way that we did for hidden states.
That's the crucial thing. So,
it's almost as if we have two different
kind of levels that we're looking at the
problem as. You know, we've got hidden
state inference being one kind of
myopically focused thing. What are the
hidden states doing as I as I observe
data.
And then
in that case that the model parameters
are held constant.
And we're just kind of looking through
them, right? It's almost like you put
your glasses on you're looking through
them. But if you want to learn what the
parameters are themselves, you have to
now stop doing hidden state inference
and do inference on the parameters. And
we can do that in the usual Bayesian
story. It's kind of like taking your
glasses off and cleaning them, okay? You
know you you're going from transparency
to opacity.
So that's and that's going to get even
more unified as we go to the the
expectation maximization algorithm,
which has not been we're not going to we
haven't covered that just just yet, so.
All that is to say is that there is yet
yet more
uh linear algebraic stuff you can do. So
go to 3.3. Oh.
Uh I'm sure we'll be able to find that
in time. 30.
32 33
>> [cough]
>> Maybe it's not there.
Uh I just wanted to say that there there
are explicit analytic
equations that will give you what the
covariance should be
and what the mean should be for the
parameter distribution, okay? And that's
that's according to to a Bayesian
update.
Uh we don't have them just yet. We'll
have to add them in.
>> [clears throat]
>> Uh and thing there's a nice figure 3.11
which which shows the result of this.
Uh well, various various settings of the
parameters. 3.11. Oh, maybe we don't
have that figure just yet. Uh no, yeah.
There we go.
So what are we looking at here? We're
looking at Bayesian linear regression.
So we're just doing Bayesian inference
on the parameters, okay?
Same story as chapter two but applied to
the parameters now.
Uh with just the prior.
So there's no samples now. We have a a
prior belief about
our our parameters.
Uh
or with samples that range from 1 to 50,
Okay, so we can take one or or 50
samples.
And the image in each panel represents
the posterior probability, so the
updated belief
uh distribution with beta one on the
x-axis and beta zero on the y-axis. So,
those are our two parameters. We have
We've only got two just now.
Uh and then the red cross
denotes the actual
value or the the setting of those
parameters that we used in the
generative process.
So,
you know, here's our prior belief. It's
pretty bad. [clears throat]
But if we have one sample, we can begin
to sort of update.
And then we we take five samples, we can
see that we're getting closer and closer
to the true value of the uh parameters.
And all the way to 50 samples, not only
are we getting closer to what the true
value of the parameters are, but our
posterior belief about what they could
be is shrinking.
So, we're getting more and more precise
about what our uh belief about the
parameters are.
And that's the crucial added jazz that
the Bayesian story gives you.
Very nice.
Okay, so that was
a whirlwind tour of chap uh you know,
section 3.1 through 3.3.
Uh very much culminating in Bayesian
linear regression.
I'd like to raise the possibility for
maybe questions now in the last sort of
10 minutes, cuz that's a lot of
material.
Um and it's maybe unclear at this point
how it all hangs together. Well, as I
say, we will see
kind of clearly how that does hang
together when we get to expectation
maximization.
But uh if there are questions, please
please do fire away.
No, yes. No.
I've tried to summarize that material
relatively um
concisely in in the sort of chapter maps
that I've I've given here. So,
all of that material is for those who
don't don't have it the at least the
core of it is is available. So,
That is 3.1 3.3.
>> [clears throat]
>> It It might sound like a lot of new
material, uh
and it is in a lot of ways in terms of
the mathematics, but
we're not really doing anything
radically different to what we did in
chapter two yet. We're just still doing
Bayesian inference. It's just there's
two things we can do inference with
respect to: hidden states or our
parameters. So, we're going to see if we
can combine them.
So.
Yes.
Let me review a chat here.
There were I I I will note there were
questions uh in the actual questions
table and they're they're on here as
well.
I haven't yet got to all of those.
Andrew, did you have something you'd
like to say?
Y- Yeah. Um well,
>> [clears throat]
>> first I do think it's it's a
a good idea to prioritize like having a
look at some of those chapter three
questions that were asked. Um I do want
to say quickly um for those who still
are still trying to gain some more um
sort of common-sensical
uh intuition about these things, um in
some ways we can think of um you know,
as we can see through some of these
equations, the the parameters are really
what shapes uh sort of how observations
get mapped to hidden states um during
inference, right? And so, during chapter
two, if we assume that those parameters
are fixed and we don't actually learn
them, we don't actually update them in
any kind of way, that means we're just
really relying upon those. In a sense,
you can think of um
you can think of parameters that make,
you know, and what their values are and
how that that overall equation sort of
looks is like sort of like a person's
understanding of how observations relate
to end states. If you lack an
understanding, then there's no way that
you could actually take you know in an
observation and infer some sort of
useful
belief from that about what's going on
in the world or otherwise. If you think
of sort of the the being in a box
example in chapter
one and two
and so here to actually update the
understanding itself. It's sort of the
difference between like you know someone
who's learning math and they're trying
to solve a math problem.
They can have their belief about what
the true correct answer is to the math
problem and they can you know take in
all kinds of sensory observations. They
can read a textbook fundamental
fundamentals of active inference or
otherwise they could take in different
kinds of information that they've read.
They can read the problem the the prompt
for the math problem itself. Right and
then they can try and infer what is the
correct answer to this question.
That said if you have a poor
understanding of math, then you're
probably going to come up with the wrong
question
or excuse me, you're going to come up
with the wrong final answer. That is
you're going to come up with a wrong
estimate for X in this case. So it's by
being able to update our understanding
are these parameters that kind of shape
our our perception of how
sensory information
we receive relates to end states. Like
without updating that understanding,
probably going to continue to get our
answers wrong. And so so we kind of have
to update what we think the right answer
is. We update our understanding, kind of
go back and forth through those two
things and that perhaps makes for a
well-rounded education anyway.
Yeah, if you want to answer any of those
questions or if anyone else has any
questions for feel free to ask them.
Yeah, I know actually all the questions
there just now
to three.
I believe they're all about things that
are beyond section 3.3.
>> [laughter]
>> So perhaps we could
well I mean we've got 4 minutes left
here so I'm not sure it pays to to begin
venturing into that territory.
Suffice it to say that I I have seen
them and I I will begin to to actually
answer them.
Um but I think it is important before we
do leap into that other material and and
ultimately culminate in expectation
maximization that we have an
appreciation for
everything that we talked about just
now.
Uh for sure. So last part of the maybe
we can
end the recording soon but if there are
if there's any questions that people do
want to ask on the recording now now
would be a good time.
But other than that I might stop the
recording.
And then we can pick up with 3.4 to 3.6
next time.
Yes.
And that really will tie that will tie
everything together with expectation
maximization. That's going to be really
cool and and juicy when we get to that
so.
All righty.
I will stop the recording but I will be
here to to answer questions for those
who don't want to be on the recording
so.
Let's do that. Stop recording. All
right.
Until next time.